So hello to friends in the room.
Friends who I know are joining us virtually.
I'm really excited that you're here and thank you Justin for having me.
It's great to be here.
Um,
this is part of a big bunch of research that I started some way or another 13
years ago in some way or another in 1996 even.
And I want to start by making the claim that architecture,
AI,
and design are all connected.
Uh,
these 60 these connections go back some 60 or 70 years to 1956 or even 1948.
And newness seems to be central to how we talk about artificial intelligence
today.
We say things like AI is the new black
AI is the new Ui.
Okay.
Artificial intelligence is the next digital frontier according to our friends at
Mckinsey.
Okay.
Andrew Ng's stated that AI is the new electricity.
But also AI is the new moon because he will be an online course that he's
running.
You need data for AI.
So data is the new oil.
Yeah.
The future of computers is the mind of a disembodied toddler head.
Okay.
And apparently I am also the new AI and I will spare you this,
uh,
what this says,
but it's really,
really sexist and really awful.
And if you want to get an idea of how much the word new gets used when we talk
about Ai,
you could look at something like this MIT technology review article.
Um,
I just highlighted the word,
knew where I could find it.
And,
uh,
there were six mentions and the first two paragraphs,
of course,
I think one of them was New York.
So I don't think that that actually counts.
And this gentleman was a part of a conversation about tech moguls declaring an
era of artificial intelligence.
But AI isn't the new because AI isn't new.
Okay.
Here's how I knew.
It's not 1955,
uh,
John McCarthy,
the founder of the Stanford Ai Lab.
And before that,
the MIT Ai lab,
um,
referred to Artefill,
coined the term artificial intelligence to me and making machines do things that
would require intelligence if done by man.
Okay.
In 1956 he brought together a group of researchers at Dartmouth College in New
Hampshire and they spent the summer hashing out what they thought the platform
of research on AI should be and it included things like neural nets and it
included,
um,
oh,
what did,
what does he say?
He says an attempt will be made to,
uh,
find how to make machines use language,
form abstractions and concepts,
self kinds of problems,
no reserve for humans and improve themselves.
We think that a significant advance can be made in one or more of these problems
if a carefully selected of scientists can work together on it for a summer.
1956,
um,
herb Simon Allan Newell and JC shot,
uh,
Simon annual,
very important to Carnegie Mellon's history,
um,
wrote in 1958 that they pretty much figured out this problem of modeling the
human brain in computing.
They said intuition into salient and learning are no longer exclusive
possessions of humans.
Any large scale,
high speed computer can be mean to pro and made to sit with them.
Also,
they believed that by the 1960s they'd have it figured it out.
Figured out.
Yeah.
And of course Marvin Minsky,
who in 1961 said,
I believe that we are on the threshold of an era that will be strongly
influenced and quite possibly dominated by intelligent problem solving machines.
Prodo machine learning.
Um,
you might find in the world of perceptrons in 1958,
um,
the New York Times published an article talking about this new navy device that
learns by doing and said that the navy revealed the embryo of an electronic
computer today that it expects will be able to walk,
talk,
see right,
reproduce itself and be conscious of its existence.
The navy said the perceptron we'd be the first non living mechanism capable of
receiving,
recognizing and identifying its surroundings without any human human training or
control.
Okay.
So all of these ideas are really old.
Um,
they're older than me by far,
and they're older than a lot of what we work on.
But in addition to this,
I want to point out that AI and architecture are old friends and kind of
cocreated each other.
At a certain point in time that in ways that has very direct impact on the kind
of engineering and design work that we do today and the problems that we focus
on.
I'm going to introduce three of the characters in my book.
Um,
artifice or architectural intelligence.
The three people I'm going to introduce in this talk are Christopher Alexander,
Cedric price and Negroponte.
Nicholas Negroponte,
who here has heard of Christopher Alexander.
Okay.
Couple.
Anyone?
Cedric price.
Okay.
Right on.
And Nicholas Negroponte.
Okay.
Couple more.
All right.
So they're all architects who worked very closely with technology and different
kinds of ways,
some,
so much so that you don't probably think of Nicholas Negroponte,
the founder of the MIT media lab as an architect.
And I'm going to talk about the ways that they worked with cybernetics and
artificial intelligence to build new kinds of worlds and new kinds of approaches
and ways that affect what we do today.
I'll start with Christopher Alexander.
Yeah.
Christopher Alexander.
If you do know of his work and even if you don't buy me putting up this book
right here,
I've probably begun to bring him into something you've heard of before.
He's written many,
many books.
He's a mathematician,
born in Vienna,
raised in England,
um,
came to the United States in the 1960s.
He's quite old but still alive.
Living in England again was a professor at Berkeley and,
um,
he,
I,
I'll mention three books today.
Uh,
notes on the synthesis of form a pattern language and the timeless way of
building notes on the synthesis of form was his,
uh,
his thesis.
And if you've ever heard the idea of design being,
um,
good fit or fitness,
you know,
trying to shim a table until it kind of works or putting a stable system in
place.
That's where that idea comes from.
Those of you who've used patterns,
whether in Ux or in software,
um,
are are right in the lineage of Christopher Alexander.
His idea of pattern languages have influenced this.
And then his philosophy of design,
which he outlined in the timeless way of building.
If you've ever used a Wiki or you use agile processes,
you have used something that,
um,
that he's done.
My own research with Alexander started when I was reading notes on the synthesis
of form a and this question of Ai came up when I realized in a footnote,
he was referring to Shannon and a Kludge Hannon,
John McCarthy and Marvin Minsky.
And I wondered,
why is this architect,
what does he have to say about artificial intelligence in 1964,
um,
13 years later,
I have a book about that
he was interested in finding ways to break down design problems so they could be
easily understood and design.
Um,
anybody who has created tree diagrams in order to explain the function of a
piece of software or a website is working in this lineage.
Um,
in fact,
this is the outputs of one of his programs from this as a something that's in
the Berkeley archives that shows how you break down the elements of a design
problem for how you design high waves.
He also applied these ideas to the bart system in 1964.
This is,
um,
390 requirements that he and his team outlined.
And,
uh,
this is before bark was built.
Um,
I'm not sure how many of these are in place today.
I think we probably need new requirements.
My ears are still ringing from the Bart ride.
I took this morning
pattern,
language and timeless way of building.
I already mentioned briefly,
but I want to tell you a little bit more about them.
Um,
the pattern language as he puts it in,
it's not the only,
it's a pattern language.
Um,
it's 253 patterns from large to small scale and then the timeless way of
buildings as a philosophy of patterns.
And these patterns are anything from how to make a nation state down to how to
organize your bedroom.
And is he,
uh,
in his and his collaborators,
right?
Each pattern describes a problem which occurs over and over again in our
environment and then describes the core of the solution to that problem in such
a way that you can use the solution a million times over without ever doing it
the same way twice.
So in the book,
here's an example of a pattern.
I live in Pittsburgh and I live in a row house and so it's very dense where I
live.
And these are patterns about the design of a row house.
You see a number of statement picture,
um,
a statement about the design problem,
illustrations to carry out to,
to explain some of what that design problem is doing and then a connection to
other patterns,
um,
in the system.
And it works sort of like an operating system.
The patterns are a network.
So you see here are a number of them in their order explaining what each of them
do.
Um,
you know,
this is going from a mosaic of some cultures all the way down to a household mix
and it goes further and further into more detail.
MMM.
Alexander is someone that a lot of technologists have read.
Um,
if you know Alan Cooper,
the a interaction designer,
he used to ferret out Christopher Alexander's books in his high school library
and read them there.
Um,
he wanted to be an architect.
So did Kent Beck and then realized he didn't want to build buildings.
He wanted to build software and there was a lot more that you could do within
that world.
And a word cutting and ham ward Cunningham and Kent Beck,
we're curious about how they could apply this idea of patterns to the idea of
object oriented programming language or this.
So they applied it to 'em interface patterns in small talk in the late eighties
and about 1987 and a community of programmers got together and over the years
built up what was called,
um,
the design patterns,
movement.
And this group of four men who called themselves the gang of four are the ones
who created this kind of network of design patterns in software.
And it's an idea that you see millions and millions of times.
I think there's something like 1200 bucks on Amazon that refer to design
patterns in,
um,
in software and in interfaces and games.
Okay?
Whatever.
Okay.
Now does this,
how many people have heard of design patterns?
There you go.
Um,
also if you've ever,
if you've ever used agile processes or,
um,
followed extreme programming,
Kent Beck and board coming Cunningham and a number of other people applied these
ideas about the philosophy of design from Christopher Alexander and the timeless
way of building to up end and change the politics of the design process and to
give more flexibility to users and to people.
And when I interviewed Kent Beck,
he told me that it was a rearrangement of the political power in the design and
building process.
Okay.
Everyone here has used a wiki and the Wiki format was developed by Ward
Cunningham.
He was developing it in,
in hypercard in the early nineties.
And then,
um,
it was suggested that he could maybe build this on this new thing called the
worldwide web.
And what he wanted to do was have a conversation that never had an end if he
wanted to map all of the knowledge he had of his,
that he and his team had.
He didn't want to say it ends here.
He wanted it to be able to go and go and go.
He never patented,
um,
the Wiki format.
And,
um,
it was picked up in the early two thousands to run Wikipedia and now we've all
used wikis one way or another.
Um,
but this is again,
a direct inspiration or,
or a director influenced by Christopher Alexander,
uh,
project.
Okay.
So that's Christopher Alexander.
And the other thing to say about him,
his architects tend to hate him and technologists tend to love him.
I'm not sure why conundrum,
but kind of interesting.
So I'd like to introduce you to a different kind of architect.
This is Cedric price.
Um,
I've called him the secret patron saint of interaction designers.
He changed the way,
um,
any number of people in the UK understood architecture and buildings and what
they could do.
Uh,
his life partner is,
uh,
was Eleanor Bron.
He died in 2003.
Eleanor Bron was in the Beatles movies and was responsible,
actually,
she was the inspiration for the song Eleanor Rigby.
So just a very curious and very funny person who liked to ask things like,
technology's the answer.
But what was the question?
And Cedric price was best known for,
um,
things that were never built.
So,
for instance,
the fun palace was designed in the 1960s and it was supposed to be a big
cybernetic theater,
um,
movable kind of place where all sorts of things could happen.
And,
um,
the space was going to learn from it's users over time and adapt to their
interests and needs and you could change it over time and use it kind of as a
big leisure center to learn and experience whatever it is you might want to
learn.
When you worked with a 25 member,
27 members,
cybernetic community,
which is what you see here on the right.
And in this particular image,
it's kind of hard to,
to read,
but,
um,
it talks about input of unmodified people and then output of modified people.
So they thought through this like a system diagram.
He did this project with Joan Littlewood who was a radical theater director and
a protege of the German playwright bear pressure.
He also was really inspired by Gordon Pask and Gordon Pask is a cybernetic
assist,
um,
who also had a big influence on a lot of,
a lot of architects and a piece that he wrote in 1969 talked about changing this
a design process and some really interesting in some interesting ways.
And he suggested that we turned the design paradigm in on itself and let us
apply it to the interaction between the designer and the system.
She designs rather than the intersection between the system and the people who
inhabit it.
So rather than the system you designing,
doing your bidding,
maybe it does something different.
Maybe it augments and create something different than what the two people put
together.
Okay.
Um,
this is a trying,
he gave him second order,
cybernetics.
Uh,
he wrote things like,
assume for the moment I'm the successful businessman with the bowler hat and I
insist that I'm the sole reality where everything else appears only in my
imagination.
I cannot deny that in my imagination there were a little purer other people,
scientists,
other successful businessmen,
et cetera.
As for instance,
in this very conference,
since I had the,
since I find these apparitions in many ways similar to myself,
I have to grant them the privilege that they themselves may insist that they are
the soul reality and everything else is a condition of their imagination.
Another hand,
they cannot deny that they're fantasies will be populated by people and one of
them may be I with bowler hat and everything.
So this is second order cybernetics where the fact that you're engaging with the
system changes to the system and if you start looking at the design process is
something that needs to take that into consideration.
Design begins to look a little bit different.
Um,
Cedric price was again very,
very inspired by his interactions and collaborations with Gordon Pask and one of
the buildings that,
or one of the projects that he designed was something called generator.
This was never built.
Um,
but it was a project that was in existence from 76 to 79 and it was a set of 12
foot cubes,
150 cubes,
walkways,
boardwalks that could be moved around and um,
and recombined for whatever purposes someone might like.
This was an arts retreat center for a wealthy patron in Florida.
He always really liked moving cranes.
So there's always a moving crane here and generator would come together like
this.
There was grid on the ground,
he put cubes over it,
roofs on top,
connect the parts,
and then you could put up the side baffles and,
um,
the stairways and do what you'd like with this space.
You could also model it with these little cubit parts,
um,
that,
that you would see.
He thought that maybe fun things might happen.
Like you could take a bleep or walk.
I will remind you,
this is 1977 or so when this idea came up.
Um,
and something strange about a mouse rolling around a cube,
but it's strange and weird and funny all the time.
And again,
we look at Gordon Pask.
Um,
Gordon Pask did a project first in 1953 and then in 1968 called,
which became the Colloquia of Mel mobiles.
And what happens with these mobiles are you interact with it and it an internet
or interacts back with you until it gets bored.
And Paul Pangero who is a cybernetic assist and um,
and a professor at the college for Creative Studies in Detroit has just rebuilt,
um,
the Colloquia of Mill Mobiles for the 50th Anniversary of the original project.
He's Gordon Pask archivist and a,
it's up right now as we speak in Detroit.
So this is what,
what does this have to do with generator?
Well,
it's hundred price realized.
It was unlikely that people are going to want to move around,
generator enough and learn from it and do the kind of funny things that it would
expect.
So he began to work with John Frazier and Julia Frazier,
who were computer scientists as well as architects and um,
wanted put together a set of programs that people could use that would be used
by generators.
So there would be micro controllers all on all of its parts and inventory
program,
a design program.
That's what you see here.
You can pick up and move these cubes and they plot in Printout,
um,
and a boarding program.
And the boredom program,
uh,
said the following in the event of the site not being reorganized or changed for
some time,
the computer starts generating unsolicited plans and improvements.
Okay.
And this is something that John Frazier wrote in his letter to Cedric price
introducing these programs.
So if we kick a system,
the very least you would expect it to do is kick you back.
And then
he said,
you seem to imply this as a handwritten footnote that you can kind of see down
here in the letter.
You seem to imply that we were only useful if we produce results that you did
not expect.
I think this was,
this leads to some definition of computer AIDS in general.
At least.
One thing that you would expect from any half decent program is that it should
produce at least one plan,
which you did not expect.
So this is where something like Gordon Pasts Colloquia mobiles makes its way
into Cedric price's architecture.
And these are ideas that we pick up today in some really lovely ways.
I'm on the next slide.
I'm going to introduce a project by the roboticist Madeline Gannon.
She just finished her phd at Carnegie Mellon.
I'm in architecture and she did an exhibition at the London Design Museum with a
robot,
a robotic arm that would um,
play with it's play with somebody in its midst until it got bored and went away,
comes together and you're in the space with the robot and you just have a very
raw experience with this animal like machine responding to your every move,
all the technical aspects sort of melt away into the background.
It's incredibly important to have opportunities and spaces to come in and
experiments and misuse these existing technologies.
Okay.
She didn't know about garden pastor Cedric price when she did this project,
but I find it compelling that many years later,
this is exactly what she is trying to do and trying to get us to rethink our
relationship with our machines.
She calls herself the robot whisperer.
Third Person I'd like to talk about is Nicholas Negroponte.
Um,
and you'll notice here he always seems to have his fingers in the picture.
He always seems to be gesturing at something.
Um,
you would probably know him as the founder of the MIT media lab,
but before the media lab,
he ran something called the architecture machine group at Mit.
And that's what I want to want to talk about here.
The Mit architecture machine group was in the school of architecture,
but worked very closely with the AI lab and developed interfaces and
environments for,
um,
for artificial intelligence.
The gesture thing.
He,
um,
he's the author of a number of books.
Um,
the book that you'd probably be most likely to know would be called being
digital and being digital came out in 1995 but in 1970 he wrote a book called
the architecture machine and he dedicated it to the first machine that can
appreciate the gesture.
Nicholas Negroponte is a clever man.
Um,
but this book I think is actually,
um,
fascinating and really important.
It was a theory of design for artificial intelligence that I think still holds
weight.
Today.
I want to point out a little bit about the funding structures of the
architecture machine group and a of artificial intelligence in general.
Um,
the architecture machine group was funded by the information processing
technology office of Darpa and the office of naval research.
Um,
the office of naval research was so important for defining the,
um,
funding for artificial intelligence from pretty much its inception onward
through the 80s.
Um,
so vital that,
um,
I think that Marvin Minsky has referred to Marvin Denekov,
who was the program officer as the grand old man of artificial intelligence.
So the thing to point out is something that,
that I'm Paul Edwards,
the historian has referred to as the closed world.
That artificial intelligence,
um,
was primarily developed within department of defense funded entities because it
meant a small group of people could continue to work on these projects through
the same social network friendship networks and professional networks that had
been developed since the end of World War II where NSF funding national science
foundation funding kind of automatically and invites very spirit,
tried to throw things open to the world and open things up and bring more people
in.
So it was desired by Darpa,
Darpa,
depto and ONR to keep funding and development in these small networks of people
and to get things done better.
And it meant that the architecture machine group started to structure their work
like the AI lab did at MIT and work very closely on interfaces and small
machines and environments for artificial intelligence.
One of these first projects was funded by IBM.
It was called urban to uh,
or urban urban too.
And then later urban five.
And it was a conversational user interface for urban design.
Um,
this is 1970.
I actually started a little bit before that.
And,
um,
what happens here is user chooses a set of blocks.
You see these squares down at the bottom and then there's a conversation going
on the side using this light pen to select questions and answers and it asks you
questions and you,
you use the conversational dialogue and the buttons to determine,
um,
what the attributes are of these,
these areas that you are designing.
So it's for urban design
and
the architecture machine group book,
um,
the architecture machine book outlines,
and critiques their,
their study here.
You might notice this last one that says Ted,
many conflicts are occurring.
And they said,
you know,
it was charming but it printed garbage,
but at least it was friendly garbage.
So the words that they used and um,
it,
I think it points out if anyone here has tried to,
has tried to design a conversational user interface.
You know,
how easy it's going to seem on the surface and how hard it is in reality.
And even Justin,
what we could look back to someone like Joseph Weizenbaum in 1966 who created
Eliza,
the therapy program.
Um,
it's a question and answer,
user conversational user interface and um,
very difficult and problematic in ways that caused Joseph Weizenbaum to rethink
his own total engagement with computation and artificial intelligence.
Um,
so everybody knows that this is difficult to do and yet we continual continually
tried to do it anyway.
MMM.
Nicholas,
Negroponte and Marvin Minsky were friends throughout their entire throat.
his entire professional life until Marvin stuff a couple of years ago.
And here you see a,
uh,
a robotic arm stacking blocks.
This is um,
a lot of AI problems were developed in what we're calling micro worlds,
right?
So you focus in on some small part of a project,
some small issue,
right?
You're looking at edge finding,
you're looking at computer vision.
In fact,
you're still today thinking about computer vision in some very specific small
ways.
Um,
I know Justin was just taking a computer vision class at Stanford,
um,
and you try to throw away the rest of the noise and just focusing on that
problem.
And that's appropriate for some period of time.
But after a while and micro worlds didn't actually scale up.
And this gets to be a problem.
Um,
but as I mentioned,
the architecture machine group worked in micro worlds as well.
An Ai Ai interfaces.
And this is a project that they did in 1974 the software show.
It was a museum show at the Jewish Museum and um,
information technology.
It's new meaning for art.
And so here you see all of these cubes,
isn't it funny?
Like generator has cubes and urban five has cubes more cubes.
And you've got this set of mirrored blocks,
400 mirrored blocks of five foot by eight foot pen and a durable hoard.
Okay.
Dribble Colony,
um,
living there.
And it's going to be difficult to read this,
but it says dribbles match wits with computer built.
And what seek did with stack blocks and what turbos did was move them around and
knock them over.
And this is the gatefold of the software catalog,
the life in a computerized environment.
And there's this great quote from a Ted Nelson who says,
our bodies,
our hardware,
our behavior software.
And it's Paul Pangero who made the contemporary Colloquia of mobiles and a
member of the architecture machine group who told me,
okay,
it was a little bit too true because seek tended to kill the dribbles
in later days.
The architecture machine group turned to commanding control interfaces that were
explicitly,
um,
that had explicit military connections and applications.
And this is because the only way past 1974 that you could get work in artificial
intelligence funded was to align it with commanding control questions and direct
tactical military applications.
This is due to some legislative things that had happened in the 70s and the wake
of the Vietnam War.
And so this is the aspen movie map.
Um,
it is kind of what it looks like.
Google street view that you experienced sitting in a room in a chair.
You zoomed down the streets of Aspen,
Colorado in an Eames lounge chair with joy pads and a video disc produces the
images for you.
They had a prototype video disc player,
uh,
in the 1970s.
And the way you get the images is everybody goes to aspen on vacation and you
load up the jeep and that's what you have right here.
Um,
so you zoom down the streets and there are other,
there are other photos that show what's in front of the,
um,
the,
the two smaller screens are usually maps and are on touch screens.
Okay.
I want to point out that part of the reason this project was funded was it was
in the wake of the,
um,
the jet rescue,
the hostage rescue in Entebbe,
Uganda.
Um,
a number of Israelis and Israeli jet had been,
um,
had been hijacked and the rescue of the hijacking was performed by building a
model desert or a model airport in the Negev desert and pre-death,
um,
practicing the rescue under cover of darkness.
Um,
in fact,
um,
this,
I think this is the subject now of a movie that's about to come out or as coming
out later this year.
Um,
and so the question here became what could be,
what would happen if you were able to actually simulate and do remote moving
and,
uh,
move down these streets?
So that would be the stipulation for this project.
Yeah.
In later years they were really explicit about this and some of them,
some of the reports they wrote,
um,
Minsky and his colleague Richard Bolt wrote that we are proposing to develop
human computer interfaces.
On the one hand is sophisticated and conception as a cockpit and on the other
hand is operationally simple as a TV.
From either perspective,
the objective is the same supreme usability.
Okay.
Later on they started delving into um,
virtual reality in certain ways and questions of augmented reality.
So this provocation and mapping by herself is a postcard held up in front of the
Queen's Palace in Stockholm and imagining what it would be like to have a screen
that overlaid information upon the world.
On the other side is a Westinghouse map Westing house window,
uh,
basically,
very early.
Um,
I pad like thing that a was still connected to various technologies and you can
kind of see in the background that there's a Selectric typewriter and a
dictaphone.
Um,
but this was a mapping window and intended to substitute from apps in the
battlefield.
It had two dimensional and two and a half d capabilities depending on how you
would flip it.
And this is apparently the first example of a layer digital map.
Okay.
I like the fact that Nicholas Negroponte,
um,
has always understood what he has been working on and the conundrums and
contradictions about it.
And in his 1975 books,
soft architecture machines,
he said,
I strongly believe that it is very important to play with these ideas
scientifically and explore applications of machine learning,
that totter between being unimaginably impressive and unbelievably exciting.
Okay.
And if I myself as,
as I look at these historical examples and where we are today,
I find myself wondering if we need new cliches because when I do Google image
search and pop in Ai,
this is what I get.
There's always this,
you know,
the way B
or the,
the behold the hand and it's always that color blue.
It's like the,
the blue of the projector when no one's in the room.
Chase on lady.
I think there are no,
this is j query,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Cyborg lady.
Um,
if these are our views of AI in the future,
I think we're in trouble.
But I appreciate some of the subversive ways that we can look at this and some
of the fun ways that we can as well.
Um,
is anyone here a fan of Chanel Shane and AI weirdness?
I nerded out so hard at io this year.
When I got to meet her,
she,
uh,
she does very funny things with AI that I'll talk about,
but I really appreciate that she understands what she's doing.
And she said,
you know,
if life place by the rule image,
the recognition works well.
But as soon as people are sheep do something unexpected,
the algorithms show their weaknesses.
So are these orange flowers in a field or sheep because she colored them orange,
it's not sure anymore.
Um,
Chanel is also done.
Things like this is 7,000.
Um,
paint colors fed to a neural net and it begins to create new colors,
all of which are terrible and color names.
Exactly.
You know,
I've,
I've been reduced to tears multiple times.
Caring can verbal,
simp turn ugly
ranching Blue Tondar.
Um,
she fed the names to the names of Guinea pigs for the Portland Guinea pig rescue
and came up with some names for Guinea pigs.
Here we have hanger Dan and Princess Pow.
And my husband has said,
you know,
I think any kid could come up with princess power,
but it takes a neural net to come up with hanger down only meets machine
learning can produce now and again,
when I think about these kinds of things,
I also find myself thinking about this,
which is actually it,
it apparently was not Marcel Duchamp who delivered this to the art show in 1917
this year,
rental as his object to pet rather a woman whose name I can't remember,
they've just surfaced that it wasn't him,
but this was part of data at some where the world was going to hell.
Um,
it was world war one and things were really,
really dark.
And so what does art mean when things are really dark means that you've got to
turn to absurdity,
you've got to turn it upside down.
And so art starts to look different.
Or you look at someone like Eugene Unesco who wrote the play Rhinoceros in 1959.
Um,
it's an absurdist play and it's where a group of people in a French town bit by
bit turned into rhinoceroses.
And of course he's talking about totalitarianism.
A UNESCO wrote a play called the bald soprano because he had started to try to
learn English.
He is a French Romanian.
And,
um,
in order to learn English,
he would type phrase after phrase from this kind of English book.
John and Sally go to the store and over and over,
and he began to question the nature of these meanings.
It's almost like he became his own algorithm in order to learn this.
And he produced a very funny play called the bald soprano about it.
Or You could even look at something like,
um,
booneyard Louie balloon,
Boone Yell,
who did,
um,
ah,
Shyanne under Lou in the 1920s,
19 teens,
but in 1970,
71,
something like that,
he did the discreet charm of the bourgeoisie,
which is about a group of people trying to have dinner.
And they just keep getting thwarted and it's a container,
well,
somewhat contemporary surrealist film,
but all of these things are ways to win.
The world is on its head.
You append it in art and I want to suggest that maybe we should be doing the
same things more frequently with our algorithms.
Can anyone name what this is?
Thank you.
Okay with saying that.
But yeah,
it's exactly what it is.
And um,
the uncanny valley is an idea from 1970 from Masahiro Mori.
And what I'm struck,
this is the idea that when robots are too similar to us,
they freak us out.
And he describes the eeriness that that produces,
but he says something else in his piece in,
in the article he wrote in 1970,
which is that it's about how we understand what makes us human.
We should begin to build an accurate map of the uncanny valley so that through
robotics research we can understand what makes us human.
Until recently,
Manuela Veloso was the head of the machine learning program at Carnegie Mellon
and I was at a conference that she was speaking at and she was talking about
machine learning is successful when it does what you expect it to do.
And for Cedric Price,
we saw the goodness of one something doesn't expect,
do what you expected to do,
but there's some dark things too.
Um,
the stories that came out earlier this spring about Poland tears,
predictive,
predictive policing in north,
in New Orleans,
and the fact that that had not been known,
not even to,
uh,
most people in the city of New Orleans,
New Orleans or city officials,
I liked the work a lot of Mimi Onuoha.
Um,
some of you may know her work,
she does a project called missing datasets and you can't,
you can't parse what you don't collect.
And so if you don't have the data,
you can't begin to Parse it.
She does this both as a tech piece and a,
a critical piece and an art piece.
So here you see a lot of folders full of missing data sets.
And of course if you go look through them,
they're all empty.
Um,
she keeps a get hub repository where she has these missing datasets.
And um,
this one,
civilians killed in encounters with police or law enforcement agencies is no
longer a missing dataset.
It's been collected.
Um,
and so she'd like to see more of those and you know,
kissing points.
Sometimes there's an activist angle to her work,
but there's also,
um,
there's also work that happens as a result and group of,
Asian actors on Broadway contacted her about the roles that are available for
Asians on Broadway.
And that Blue Line is the Asians,
the Asian roles in the play,
the king and I,
and a,
the other bright light blue that you see are Asian roles elsewhere in the 2014,
20,
15 season.
Um,
similarly you can see the problems for black actors are Hispanic actors,
just not a lot available,
um,
at that point.
But by collecting this data,
it became possible to change the equation.
And now there are more Asian actors on Broadway.
This is not a matter of an algorithm,
but it's just quite simply a matter of the collection of data and collecting the
Neda and naming it,
making changes.
Oprah.
But I'm,
I'm struck by the things that machines don't do,
that we don't have good machines for picking raspberries and we kind of do for
picking strawberries,
but it's very,
very difficult to get this right to manipulate,
to,
to do this properly.
And I'm struck by the fact that if you,
um,
I think it was in Sweden,
there was a mining operation that had a truck that had some very nice,
um,
machine learning algorithms operating it more efficiently and it was so
efficient that it dug itself into a Rut and couldn't get back out.
So they had to introduce noise into the system to allow for the,
um,
I love for the vehicle to not to expertly dig itself into the ground.
So in closing,
I'll say that AI is new,
but it's also old and that it is a matter of architecture.
It's a matter of infrastructure and it's a matter of how we design.
This is something I see in my neighborhood in Pittsburgh.
I go running by Carnegie robotics.
Not totally sure how I feel about it.
Um,
okay.
Yeah,
I'm still not sure how I feel about it,
but I think it's pretty compelling.
Um,
but this is the thing that he did come back to over and over again,
which is our man Cedric price just says technology is the answer.
But what was the question?
Thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
my name is Avi and Molina.
I'm an analyst here at Google.
Um,
and I've been getting really interested in,
uh,
some of the things happening in the edge of this space,
like generative design and some of the stuff that autodesk is working on.
Yeah.
And I'm curious as to how,
uh,
where are you see the space evolving,
sort of like fastest because you know,
like three d printing,
you know,
they're usually industries,
but pick it up first.
Like where do you see like the first sort of mass market,
a case of an architectural,
you know,
AI or intelligence really happening?
That's a really good question.
Um,
I'm not sure if I,
if I have a well thought out answer.
Um,
but I point out that the history of three d printing is already quite old.
And so what we see the uptake in now,
um,
at a consumer level or at a professional level as well.
And the other thing is I don't think that three d printers,
I think they became something that it was Sunday we're going to transform
everything in the world.
And so then everybody started getting Mayberg maker spaces.
And I'm not sure that that has actually printing objects has made the world
change.
But the question of generative design,
I think that architecturally the primary focus has been on form and
representation.
You know,
you,
you use,
um,
any number of authoring programs and sign programs to produce,
produce work that you wouldn't be able to otherwise.
I get very curious again about these old ideas that I still think,
um,
are our vital about how they change the design process and the ingredients that
go in that make us think of something that isn't necessarily just ending up in
form but ending up in how we construed design.
But that's,
yeah.
Thanks.
It's a good question.
Now I'm going to try and figure out the,
uh,
so a row hit says
any thoughts on Bill Mitchell's role?
A city of yeah,
or urban design on software.
Yes.
Other than Sim city.
Ah,
chill.
Um,
Bill Mitchell was at points,
the dean of the school of architecture at Mit.
He ran the smart cities lab,
absolutely vital individual.
He's actually an alum of my master's program and he died about five years ago.
Um,
and I didn't write about him very much in my book.
I was focusing on a slightly earlier era.
Um,
but he's,
he's a totally vital figure and there's a woman named Anne Marie Brennan Right
now.
Um,
she's a graduate of my phd program in Melbourne,
Australia,
who's been working on some of his work and using his archive there.
So I think we're gonna see some stuff forthcoming about Bill Mitchell,
but you also see his work in,
you see his,
how he's inspired people including like Anthony Townsend who wrote the book
smart cities.
Um,
and has been thinking a lot for the last 20 years on urban planning,
smart cities and development.
Um,
I guess from a smart city perspective,
I keep going back to two big concerns that smart cities tend to be.
Um,
and again I get to say this cause I'm an academic I guess,
but there um,
it seems to be viewed as the locus of really great big enterprise deployments.
Like if we used to get excited about enterprises,
the scale of the building or a campus,
this is even yet still more tech and a lot of it hasn't been very graciously
designed.
I also think of that idea of micro worlds that the question of scale is really
vital.
But when we say scale,
it means a lot of different things.
Like is it one to a billion?
Is it tiny?
Two great big is it has many more users is it has many more stakeholders.
And I think designers and architects are really well positioned to talk about
issues of scale.
Um,
but it's,
it's the hardest thing I think for us to figure out what we mean when we mean
deploying on that kind of skill.
Thank you,
Rohit.
Okay.
Hi,
my name is Christine.
I just wanted to ask like,
what are you most excited about,
um,
that's getting like research now or at an idea that's,
you might have just heard about like what in this field are you most excited
about?
Thanks for that question.
That's really nice thing to be asked.
Um,
well I recently received this named professorship and it's,
it's,
uh,
the KNL gates professors,
associate professors have been the ethics and computational technologies.
I'm not an ethicist,
I'm a designer and I'm a historian and I'm really curious about what we talk
about when we talk about ethics because I don't think that it means ethics per
se.
Um,
I like,
you can't just sprinkle some ethics on top and make the food salty and,
and that,
that doesn't work.
And it makes me remember that time in like the nineties and two thousands when
people discovered usability and said,
we need some usability on this website.
And,
and like,
no,
you don't want usability.
You want it to work,
you want it to be good.
And I'm going to leave here and go to Stanford to meet up with Fred Turner,
um,
who,
if you haven't read his,
um,
recent pieces in logic and in zero 32 c you should,
the zero 32 c piece came out this week.
The piece and logic has a few months old.
So he's the head of the communications department and he's a historian of,
among other things,
silicon valley.
Um,
and we're grappling with the question about education and he's,
he's speaking about engineering,
writing about engineering education.
But I mean,
I think anyone who's going to work with stuff,
how,
how do we educate people?
Engineers are increasingly,
Fred will argue,
stem oriented,
and then anything else has relegated to other departments.
But how do you make an ethical approach to not be a blow off class?
How do you make it be a part of the datasets that year or the problem sets
you're working on?
Um,
part of my interest in casting the role of it,
of design to work in different kinds of areas,
um,
is because of that.
I'd like to,
you can,
you can work with designers on framing a problem,
determining what data should be collected,
how it should be used,
how it should be visualized or explained.
Um,
so I have questions about that.
I have questions about the possibilities and impossibilities of explainable AI.
And honestly,
if you just sit me down with like a new history or a bunch of documents about
the history of Ai,
you won't see me for a while because I'll be very happy if I can come back into,
into that stuff.
But I think we have some very human questions that also meet the jobs of the
people in this room and the people on my campus and probably the places that we
all studied,
um,
that need broader approaches than just the most efficacious and effective and
efficient approach.
Thanks.
So,
one more question from the dory.
Uh,
also from hit,
uh,
why aren't there more real architects,
celebrated in the field of software architecture other than Christopher
Alexander
for asking.
This is so great.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
I asked Alan Cooper a couple of years ago,
can you name another architect?
And I did this to Kent Beck too,
and silence for,
and I think that Kent Beck said La Qorvis Yay.
And I think Alan Cooper said,
uh,
oh,
I said John Portman,
the guy who did the Embarcadero center and you know,
the,
the Bonaventure in,
in La.
Um,
it would be better if we had other architects,
but I think the other thing is that Christopher Alexander as a mathematician,
um,
and as something,
I mean,
it's something that everyone in the room deals with.
Do you work on some very tiny part of an absolutely huge problem?
How do you go back and forth?
How do you keep that in your head?
And Christopher Alexander can explain that to people in a way that is really,
really,
that really resonates with them.
The,
the working on these two scales and then explaining why it actually matters on
like a cosmological sense,
his late stuff is,
is very woo woo.
Um,
and,
and that,
that really resonates and it really doesn't resonate with most architects who
build buildings.
So,
um,
I,
I would like to see Chris or I'd like to see Cedric price get taken up by
everyone else cause he's fun.
Um,
Alexandra is not much fun.
but Cedric's and a blast.
Um,
and to get to know other architects out there,
I think that the classes of people over about the last four or five years to
graduate from architecture school or design school or those of you were in the
spaces,
that crossover really doing interesting work and interesting ways of thinking
about it.
Um,
if you want to look at something fun,
look at my friend Fred Sherman's work.
He's an architect,
he's a professor at Morgan State and uh,
he has a book coming out on space architecture,
like space exploration,
architectural histories next year.
So fantastic stuff
through your talk.
I think,
um,
sometimes when you mentioned a,
I like,
I would consider it as like more like human computer interaction.
The reason I'm saying that is because like I'm an engineer,
so like when I get my phd like more than 10 years ago.
So like if you have a phd in Ai is not as easy to find a job as now.
Yup.
Right.
So in my understanding led,
we have a law breakthrough in AI,
like caught her Raji,
I'm talking about like for example,
Alpha goal.
Yep.
Or like image recognition.
Totally.
Or if you look at it like the IBM Watson,
right.
So when they won't the jeopardy show that time.
Yep.
So we're talking about like that a different type of a,
I caught her algae advancement and that's reason it brings back the trend of Ai.
But this is quite different from what you're talking about.
Like the human computer interaction.
So,
and I think IBM call it like cognitive computing.
So would you,
would you agree with me if like I tried to understand when you say AI is more
like human computer interaction,
which is not core AI ever from that we're talking about.
So,
um,
yes and no.
Um,
thank you for that.
That's great.
And to be,
to be clear,
the focus of my research in this book is 1960.
I mean to some extent,
1948 cause I look at cybernetics a lot,
but um,
to really about 1977,
1980.
Um,
the parts of the book that are focused on,
on later material are not focused on questions of Ai.
And I agree with you that they are questions of human computer interaction.
Um,
but I would say that when Negroponte was writing this book,
he was writing the book in 1970 and doing the work in 1970.
He was developing interfaces with the AI lab using their technologies and their
environments and basically tinkering and working in,
in that capacity.
So yes,
they are.
It's input and output devices and um,
and all kinds of ways that the lab over that,
that period of time played with that it becomes human computer interaction.
But I don't think HCI is the field really kind of comes together in that term
until the 1980s.
I,
I'd need to look at my notes to remember exactly when I will say that I'm very
curious about what happens in the Hci community around 1990 because there's some
interesting crossovers that I think have,
have things to do with HCI and interaction design in ways that are in things
that are really vital.
Um,
and yeah,
I would also agree with you that things are way more complex today and I have
skated by all of it.
So,
um,
my understanding of it is more nuanced.
But again,
I'm also,
I'm a historian of technology and architecture and I'm not someone who got my
phd in Ai.
But yeah,
when you start looking at it today and the implications,
um,
and the different kind of terms that people are claiming,
cognitive computing,
deep learning,
um,
there was a whole different set things to start looking at and studying their,
their histories.
They're going back to the 1980s,
1970s that I haven't yet gotten into.
But it's,
you're,
you're right and,
and yes,
but no,
but yes.
Thank you for that.
Thank you so much everyone for coming out today.
Thank you.